South Korea's military has apologized
for its failure to shoot down any of the
North Korean drones that crossed over
the Border it was the first such
incident in five years and raised
serious questions about seoul's air
defenses in response the country's
President says he will accelerate plans
to create a specialized military unit to
deal with drones as tensions increase
across the Korean peninsula
on the hunt South Korean helicopters
scoured the sky for signs of North
Korean drones
authorities here say five crossed over
the border on Monday with one flying
close to the capital Seoul but now the
military has been forced to say sorry
after failing to shoot them down
are military's lack of preparedness has
caused Great concern
the military will thoroughly check each
troop's detection and strike assets
against the enemy's drone provocation
an actively employ detection devices to
spot drones earlier and aggressively
deploy strike assets
South Korea's president Yoon sakiol who
has vowed to take a harder line on the
North has used the moment to fast
forward his plans telling a cabinet
meeting that the military's training and
Readiness has been insufficient for
years
we have a plan to create a military
drone unit tasked with monitoring key
military facilities in North Korea
will advance the establishment of the
Drone unit as soon as possible
we'll also introduce state-of-the-art
stealth drones and bolster our
surveillance capabilities
across the border in Pyongyang leader
Kim Jong-un is capping the Year by
meeting with key members of his ruling
party where he's hailed the country's
growing economic and military power the
north has fired a record number of
missiles in 2022 with its latest drone
incident adding to Growing concerns
across the region
journalist Frank Smith is monitoring the
situation in Seoul there Frank the
military itself has acknowledged its
response was to the drones was
inadequate uh what does it say about
South Korea's air defenses
well I think it it says that South
Korea's air defenses are sorely lacking
they were pursuing these drones for
something like five hours when they
launched a propeller aircraft from the
center of the peninsula to try to
intercept these drones that actually
crashed the two pilots had to eject from
that aircraft so there were a lot of
problems with South Korea's pursuit of
these they they shot at at least some of
the drones didn't manage to shoot any
any of them down this is concerning here
in South Korea analysts say that North
Korea has something like 300 to a
thousand drones and they do represent a
surveillance risk if not an attack risk
based on their size in 2017 a drone was
found here in South Korea that had
traveled something like 200 kilometers
south of Seoul to photograph an
anti-ballistic missile a U.S
anti-ballistic missile base here so this
type of activity from North Korea should
they succeed in in gaining better
surveillance
information on the south side of the
Border it does more to increase the time
sorry to decrease the amount of time
that South Korea would have of an
imminent North Korean attack and also
increase the potential risk of some type
of miscalculation on the Korean
Peninsula as we've seen through North
Korea's development of uh Hypersonic
missiles cruise missiles and submarine
launch ballistic missiles this increases
the risk as it decreases the amount of
warning of of some type of imminent
attack and that's really what these
drones are are doing here so with this
with this increased risk what kind of
response can I expect from South Korea
well South Korean president Yun sukyo
has said from his campaign he came to
power here in may he said that he was
going to respond to North Korea with a
much harder line on North Korea's
missile launches following North Korea's
missile launches for example South Korea
conducted its own missile launches
together with the U.S South Korea also
conducted large-scale military exercises
with the U.S with plans to perhaps
conduct the largest ever military
exercises to commemorate 70 years of U.S
South Korea Alliance next year so we're
likely to see more large-scale drills
here as well as was mentioned in the
report the development of South Korean
drones more South Korean drones with a
bigger budget
journalist Frank Smith there in Seoul
for us thank you Frank